- - Hélène Buzzati, Christine
bobonsoir
- - Je vais revenir sur les
sosondages quand même légers qui
coconfirment ce que les autres
didisaient depuis maintenant trs
ouou quatre jours. Certainemente
nanano circule Main Street, etc.
LeLes conservateurs sont passés
dedevant. En regard de tableaux
d'd'intentions de vote au Canad.
LeLes conservateurs qui sont
prpromis à 34 %., Les libéraux à
3030, et le NPD à 24 %. C'est pr
lele Canada. Au Québec, ça bouge
unun peu moins. Un tour de tabl,
HéHélène, évidemment les
prprojections de siège, c'est ac
leles chiffres d'aujourd'hui
momontrent qu'il n'y a pas de
mamajorité pour Monsieur Trudea.
OnOn se demande s'il va voir mêe
unune victoire.
- - Vous êtes exclamés tout à
l'l'heure Patrice avec votre bon
sesens qui nous a tout un peu
ininférieur. Je dirais que
MoMonsieur Trudeau utilise un pu
dedes mots pires que ça en ce
momoment quand il voit ses
chchiffres. Écoutez il jouait sn
vava-tout pour aller chercher ue
mamajorité, mais au périmètre
rereconduit entrouvert. Mais ile
popourrait très réaliste manquee
popouvoir les glisse entre les
mamains. Ce n'est pas ce qu'il
esespérait. Le vote libéral est
plplus efficace que celui des
coconservateurs qui se trouvent
plplus concentrés dans certaines
rérégions.
EnEn Alberta, mais là, tout est
popossible. Il reste encore tros
sesemaines pour les débats.
MoMonsieur Trudeau à la vie prot
lele plus compliqué de ce qu'il
pepensait lorsqu'il a déclenchée
1515 août dernier.
- - Oui. On ne sait pas. Soyons
prprudents. Comme dit Hélène, ls
lilibéraux peuvent être plus
efefficaces. Le NPD peut juste
babaisser avant. Les gens
popourraient dire qu'ils n'ont s
enenvie de gouvernement
coconservateur non plus.
- - Wiskus ce qui pourra rêver,a
veveut pas dire que ça va arriv.
OnOn voit des questions de
lélégislation suivante : ça
dedevient très serré à la fin,
esest-ce que ça vous seriez plus
enenclins à voter pour les
lilibéraux ou les conservateurs?
IlIl y a beaucoup de mouvements
popossédant les libéraux. Ceci
ététant dit, Monsieur Trudeau et
lalargement responsable je diras
dudu pétillement de son parti.
DaDans le fond, il est presque u
mmême niveau qu'en 2019. Ce sont
leles conservateurs, c'est-à-die
ququelque part un peu; mais les
coconservateurs ne sont pas de
prprogrès. Quand je dis que c'et
lala faute de Monsieur Trudeau,
ququand on demande aux gens deps
unune semaine est-ce que l'image
dede Monsieur Trudeau s'est
amaméliorée aussi détériorer sen
vovous? Et 41 % disent que l'ime
ququ'ils ont de Monsieur Trudeau
s's'est détérioré. Et seulement7
% % qui se sont améliorés. Danse
cacas de Monsieur autour le c'et
lala même chose. Alors Monsieur
TrTrudeau à un examen de
coconscience affaire. C'est
bebeaucoup lui; évidemment ces
chchef du parti, c'est normal. a
peperformance déçoit beaucoup de
gegens.
- - Christian.
- - C'est une autre preuve que s
cacampagnes électorales changent
leles choses. Avant le
dédéclenchement des élections, s
PaParti libéral semblaient avoir
dedes chances d'être majoritair.
LeLe jour de l'élection. Cette
réréserve étend faite, Monsieur
TrTrudeau semble avoir perdu son
papari. C'est un secret de
popolichinelle que la seule rain
avavant d'élection c'est avoir n
gogouvernement majoritaire. Ce
sosont pas mal exclus en
dédéfinitive. C'est un peu
SoSolange. Il joue quand même sn
gogouvernement et son avenir
pepersonnel. Ce son échec à lui.
EtEt je prévois que la campagne
cocommence à peine à être faite,
çaça va être féroce et vicieux.
LeLes libéraux ne se laisseront
papas battre comme ça. Il faut
s's'attendre vraiment à des
atattaques très intenses.
- - Je ne sais pas si vous avez
reremarqué que depuis vendredi,
MoMonsieur Trudeau a changé de n
unun peu. Hélène vous le suit
bebeaucoup, quand il a humilié s
mamanifestations, il a commencéà
fafaire des déclarations non
crcryptées. On a l'impression
ququ'il prend la mesure du comb.
IlIl va falloir qu'il même s'il
rereste minoritaire.
- - J'ai senti effectivement à
plplusieurs reprises, il est soi
dudu script. On sent qu'il parle
lilibrement, sans lire ces note.
EtEt c'est ce qu'il a toujours
seservi, mais depuis plusieurs
annénées, depuis que les premies
miministres, il s'est enfoncé ds
cecette façon de lire un peu de
mamanière presque robotique
totoujours les mêmes lignes. Et
d'd'y faite que ça fait 17 mois
ququ'on l'entend, il y a peut-êe
unune certaine lassitude s'est
ininstallé dans l'électorat. Pe-
êêtre que sa survie va passer pr
çaça, redevenir un peu plus
auauthentique, et parler avec le
cocoeur. Mais je dirais que ce
seserait aussi vrai pour Erin
O'O'Toole, il n'est pas
paparticulièrement ce n'est pas
tatant qu'il est impressionnant,
quque Monsieur Trudeau nous
dédéçoit.
- - Il a réussi Erin O'Toole une
chchose : ce ne pas faire part.l
n'n'impressionne pas mais ne fat
papas peur.
- - Oui c'est tout à fait juste,
mmême c'est des éléments qui
prprêtent effrayant dans son
paparti. Mais jusqu'à présent, e
cece soit sur l'avortement,
l'l'environnement s'est déjà un
pepeu moins évident que Monsieur
ErErin O'Toole est capable de
lilivrer quelque marchandise que
cece soit. Mais sur la médecine
prprivée, ça n'a pas levé
bebeaucoup. Et quand je regarde
sosondages de légers, tant qu'on
dedemande aux gens : est-ce que
vovous seriez d'accord qu'il y a
plplus de médecine privée dans a
sasanté? C'est très magique Armd
ououi à condition qu'il y ait
totoujours un système public
didisponible. Mais autrement di,
çaça n'a pas eu l'effet
épépouvantail que Monsieur Trudu
popouvait penser.
- - Une chose que Monsieur Trudu
esest tellement surpris, je pene
ququ'il pensait capitaliser sur
totout ce que le gouvernement
avavait fait dans la pandémie. l
y y a une question déjà on demae
: : est-ce que vous trouvez que
c'c'est la bonne façon? Que
cocontinue comme ça ou trouver e
auautre orientation pour la
papandémie? Et 62 % disent que a
prprendre autre chose. Quoi? Je
pepense que les gens ne le savet
papas. Mais Monsieur Trudeau fat
momoins de gains avec sa notione
papandémie qu'il aurait pu pens.
EtEt je pense que ce n'est pas
tetellement que les gens ne savt
papas quoi lui reprocher, mais s
gegents sont tellement années.Ça
sese reflète dans leur attitude.
- - Mais vous avez dit la
lalassitude, il y a beaucoup dea
ququ'on entend au point
- - C'est important ce que dit
MiMichel, les gents sont tellemt
anannées de la pandémie que
MoMonsieur Trudeau est associé à
lala pandémie. Et ça vaut aussi
popour Monsieur Legault. On voit
quque le contexte endémique état
exexceptionnel. Les premiers
miministres qui étaient là, on e
raralliait derrière eux, c'est n
anannexe est normal. En campagne
élélectorale c'est autre chose.
ErErin O'Toole est très difficie
àà diaboliser. Les conservateurs
c'c'était effrayant, je trouve a
bebeaucoup comme mots. Et surtot
ququand enjeu est-ce qu'on va vr
nonouvelle gouvernement
miminoritaire libéral? Ou
gogouvernement minoritaire
coconservateur qui sera sous
susurveillance des autres parti?
EnEn fait il y a parti pour quea
popolitique soit morale. C'est
trtrès moral, excellence en
cacampagne électorale Monsieur
TrTrudeau avec la seule motivatn
d'd'être majoritaire. Il n'a pas
étété capable de nous convaincre
ilil y avait autre chose. Il y a
unune sanction d'après ce qu'on
cocomprend.
- - On verra comment va se jouer
lele thème de la vaccination
ggâteau ou non. Est-ce qu'il y a
enencore des manifestations?
L'L'environnement ce que ça va u
papas? C'est loin d'être fini.
MaMais Jean Lapierre disait : ls
gegens ne votent pas avec ce
ququ'ils ont reçu, c'est un bon
cocoup pas mais ils en votent ac
leles sports de l'avenir. Hélèn,
MoMonsieur Trudeau incarna
papandémie. Est-ce qu'on a reçu
dadans le passé.
- OuOui. J'allais dire parce que
ChChristian ne parla un peu, mas
susur la vexation gâteau, Monsir
TrTrudeau joue un jeu dangereuxà
esessayer de dire qu'il n'y a qe
dedeux options possibles : ou bn
onon est pour la vaccination et
dodonc la vaccination obligatoi,
ouou alors on est contre la
vavaccination obligatoire et doc
onon est sûrement quant à
vavaccination, compter mesure
SaSainte-Anne, on est un peu la
cocourse rationalise, en étant
dédéchaînée.
- - Je serai absent dans le regd
dede Christian je n'ai pas tout
seseul de dire ça.
- - Yves-François Blanchet,...
- - je pense que cette approche
bibinaire, ne sert pas Monsieur
TrTrudeau. Et justement Michelle
mementionnait, 62 % des gens qui
veveulent une nouvelle approchee
lala pandémie. Je ne sais pas si
MoMonsieur Trudeau peut vraiment
fafaire des points avec cette
vavaccination obligatoire
- - Yves-François Blanchet, à
ShSherbrooke, avec à Ildar,
l'l'épouse de Badawi qui est
totoujours emprisonnée. Les
jojournalistes veulent parler àa
prprendre date. Voici ce qui est
ararrivé.
YVYVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chchef, Bloc québécois
- - Madame Haidar, pourquoi
avavoir soutenu publiquement
MaMaxime Bernier en 2018?
- - Je ne crois pas qu'on va
prprocéder à ça ici ce matin,
jeje suis désolé.
- - Donc on ne peut pas interror
lala candidate, mais donc vous,
ququ'est-ce que vous en pensez?
- - J'en pense que Madame Haidaa
eueu un cheminement qui l'a
amamenée... il y a déjà un bon
momoment d'ailleurs. Ça n'avait
papas marché la première fois,
êêtre candidate pour le Bloc
ququébécois. Et éventuellement,
leles journalistes auront
l'l'occasion de poser la questi.
MaMadame Haidar est un emblème
dede liberté, d'égalité des sex,
dede liberté d'expression
etet de laïcité.
- - Mais le chef ne la laisse ps
paparler. Christian qu'est-ce qe
vovous en pensait
- - C'est franchement gênant. Ee
vivient d'Arabie Saoudite, on au
soson parcours héroïque très
dodouloureux. On rabaisse les
fefemmes systématiquement. Ellee
reretrouve au Canada, au Québect
onon la rabaisse. On a la laisse
papas parler. Surtout qu'ensuite
elelle a expliqué pourquoi
l'l'avaient eu des sympathies pr
MaMaxime baignaient. Elle se
dédéfendait très bien. Monsieur
BlBlanchettes est un donneur de
leleçons. Il commence à trébuch.
EtEt aussi ce qu'il a dit sur
MoMonsieur Trudeau quand qui
lalaissa attendre que Monsieur
TrTrudeau court après les
prproblèmes suite. Mais à son
égégard, je trouve que c'est une
grgrosse gaffe. Je ne suis pas e
gegenre de dire ça d'habitude,
mamais ce que lui fait ça c'état
unun homme?
- - En fin de semaine, vous l'az
apappelé le smack, qu'est-ce que
vovous pensez de cet épisode?
- - Il faisant le smart. C'est
teterriblement paternaliste
emembrassa candidate, qui est ue
cacandidate vedette. En principe
onon avait la poussée de l'Avent
plplutôt que d'essayer de la
cacacher. Autre part, remarqueza
meme surprend pas, Monsieur
BlBlanchet a toujours été très
cocondescendant avec la presse.n
didisant : vous pose pas de
ququestions réussies... et troie
élélément je pense que Monsieur
BlBlanchet est i insécure. Il at
pepeur d'un autre dérapage. &&-a